hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to weekly update number for
freaking I missed last week's episode
because that was so busy I don't
actually remember why I'm trying to take
these shades off because because it's
like 9pm um but yeah I have to walk
sideways now apparently so I'm missed
last week's episode because anyway this
week's episode is going to be frickin
intense because I'm going to talk about
stuff so weak how is my week how's my
two weeks cuz i missed last week's
episode well two weeks was good um again
that that that thing I was talking about
I was working with another company
developing like a series that thing is
like pretty much the trailer for that is
actually going to be out pretty soon and
I'll definitely go to make a video
dedicated to that when that actually
come when that actually as so i'll
definitely you guys to that and you're
gonna love it alright so I know lot of
you guys were asking about the minecraft
server because you're all like dude
what's up with the minecraft server well
I didn't really like multiplayer hosting
to be honest I don't know why watch
where I'm going I don't know why but
maybe it was just me but FTB just kept
crashing on me and I didn't didn't
really like it so I said I actually
signed up with a different housing
company and hopefully these guys are
better because I'm all for one they
actually host it on the west coast of
the US so a lot of your guys connections
will be better I guess you're from the
US or that sort of area walk around to
that fence um but yeah no that's that's
definitely cool i'm still trying to
organize and getting like mine crack
running so Mindcrack is actually um
gonna go this way minecrack for those of
you don't know is basically Minecraft
version one point four point six and
it's a bunch of mod it still has fed the
base it's all made by fender bass team
but it's basically a bunch of mods for
it basically a bunch of mods for
Minecraft and there's actually a lot
more mods there than there are in feed
the beast this is crazy what I'm doing
right now welcome backwards man because
I own this city but yeah so I'm that
minecraft server it's going to be up
pretty soon I'm still trying to organize
minecrack get it around that you guys
will have to launch Michael a month mind
not minecraft mindcrack
well that's actually really similar
sounding isn't it they got to like fix
that but um whole guys guys this rough
neighborhood am i right ruff I'm telling
you trippin rough day but it can get out
of here think what good so only way
Mindcrack so once i get all this all
that server installed all the mods
installed all that and the surf is
actually up and running and stable I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you guys
the IP i'm also going to tell you guys
how you can actually connect those over
because it is a little different than my
previous minecraft server but it is
still some pretty good into work awesome
all right question time with children so
I don't know how long I can actually sit
here because again man rough
neighborhood but this time I'm gonna ask
you your guys questions on Facebook
because I usually usually grab the
Twitter but today we're gonna go with
Facebook just to mix it up cuz you know
me right I like mixing it up by the way
I didn't forget the microphone thing so
i'm actually using a friend's camera to
film this so i am mixing up because the
cameras on the inbuilt microphones like
a cannon video cameras on DSLR video
camera so um so yeah but yeah it's got
burn your marking it it's about
different liking it so i am I am still
keeping that I'm mixing it up boys and
girls vxo facebook um when are you going
to join a company asked Jaden bomb man I
am my own company bro get on my level
question number two will you make
software programming tutorials I made
Charles that will show you how to how to
build a java application but not a game
um possibly because I actually go into
programming by building nine games by
building actually but actually building
on
you know desktop application so i might
possibly go into that enough people
interested but um yeah might do some
because I suppose they're like the
network portion of game programming as
well when we get to that that all sort
of you know how real life from real life
I guess effects on actual network card
so it's the same four games in on games
so there'll be a lot of technical sup
there but I'm on that problem okay do
you like waffles asks coupon Wilkins um
yes I love waffles actually got six
waffles for Christmas yes Christmas ever
all right I'm gonna answer one more
question because apparently this guy's
middle name is star wars one word by the
way so Alexander Star Wars the telson so
this guy's legit someone answer his
question what will the future episodes
of game programming acted out now that
doesn't really make any sense but if he
means what will the future episodes game
programming entail basically what all
they contain pretty awesome stuff
because you know as we get more along to
the game i'm actually going to get you
guys from the community you're like
you're already making like tiles and
graphical assets for me we're going to
go even further we use facebook polls
make sure you guys like like my page on
facebook so you can vote in the future
polls all linked to my face because in
the description but yeah in those poles
i'll actually asked you guys what
features of the game i should like you
know put in and stuff like that or like
what methods like what the characters
should do you know somebody i can't
really think of anything on the spot but
things like you know should you have a
crossbow or a sword in a bottle of all
those gameplay and most elements you
guys blast you brought upon so make sure
to click on a link in the description
don't know that facebook page and like
it because i'm in the future again
you'll be learning for these awesome
game feature so yeah that's a guess the
future is going to be awesome
alright guys thanks for nine thousand
one hundred subscribers but if he hit in
10k soon [ __ ] is going to get real when
that happens also one more like small
announcement that I wanted to announce I
said this is a freaking huge
announcement on my second channel my
gaming channel again linked to that is
in the description it's YouTube
conversation then mr Turner I'm going to
be doing a far cry 3 playthrough there's
a lot of you guys have been requesting
it it's one of my favorite games like
that I've ever played definitely my
favorite game of 2012 so I'm definitely
going to be doing like a full
playthrough with that with a face cam
with commentary obviously with live
commentary and and it's going to be a
blast it's going to be awesome so make
sure to subscribe to that channel if you
guys are interested and yes i'll see you
guys there but until then see you in
another video
you